[Music]
hello Portugal hello how are you all
doing excellent having a good afternoon
staying awake after lunch well after
kind of lunch all day and it was kind of
difficult all right how many people did
their first time to end EC Porto every
hand should go up my name is Spencer
Schneider Bock and I'm here to talk to
you today about expression trees in
c-sharp not only what they are a little
bit but how they're used today and how
you could use them give you some ideas
jog your memory jog your brain a little
bit to give you some ideas how you might
be able to use them in your day to day
first things first
this is my Twitter it's action item Bach
and you can find all the slides plus
more action IDEs net or if you just
follow me on Twitter
I'll be doing this a few times
throughout the presentation right click
on this handy little link and then I
suite out exactly what I'm talking about
there you go first things first tweet
out a link to the slides I have a few
code examples in here that use a.net
fiddle so you're able to hit fret play
in the browser and follow right along
and or do it after the after the talk is
over so let's dive right in and get
started how many people have ever
queried a database with a link
expression something like this where
you're doing a fromwhere select and then
you've got and grab a handful of
properties all right entity framework
hands up and any framework pulps very
good how many people see still use link
to sequel maintaining some kind of okay
there's a few very good very good
or in hibernate even all right so if
you've done if you've done something
like this
then that means that you probably used
expression have you ever been asked to
rent do something like this where you're
asked there are how many Razer
developers anybody using ASP net web MVC
very good or ASP net for where you're
able to do we're able to go into your
razor view and you do at and then you do
HTML editor for and you've created some
kind of strongly typed model and you say
well I need to be able to type a first
name in for this employee or whatever
how many people have done thing like
this very good and how many people have
in some arbitrary way for some library
at any point have ever been asked to
select a member a specific member from a
an object you give it a tight you give
it some that you uh you have a it has a
type it knows that you're looking for
the employee and you give it a lamb to
something like this where you're trying
to select us the name how many people
have done something like this very good
alright well if you've done something
like this
you used expression trees at some point
in your c-sharp life even if you had no
idea
so first thing I'm going to talk about
I'm going to talk briefly about what
expression trees are first before we can
talk about those we've got to talk about
lambda expressions right or lambdas
whatever you want to call them something
like this so if you're able to you could
use a local function you declare it
inside of a variable if you do something
like funk of string string which is just
saying I am a function I take in a
string and I return a string and then
you set it to some arbitrary variable
call it to upper and then you're able to
actually set it to something like this
where you go string goes into string to
upper and what you've done is you've
literally just created a method inline
inside of a variable most of us have
done stuff like this this is not news to
and this is probably not news to many of
you or then you're able to capture that
and able to go and capture call that
method right there because it's a valid
method at that point and you're able to
pass in an argument in this case pass in
my name what happens and you pass that
into that you get that you get my name
back it's just capital letters right
call into upper very good all right
straightforward so far
so then we declare it again in a
different set of code and at this time
we don't declare it as funk of string
string we declare it as expression of
funk of string string do the same thing
the syntax is all over all together
pretty much the same and this time we
try to call our to upper method on art
on our Spencer character and then what
happens nothing happens because it
doesn't compile it doesn't compile
because this is by definition that isn't
a function this isn't a function in the
purest sense the word at least not yet
so what the heck do we have because what
we have here is something that are two
things that are syntactically similar
they're pretty note that's done
tactically the same the only difference
is the way that we've declared them and
the key difference to understand if
you're trying to understand what a
lambda is versus Innis an expression is
that a lambda does the thing it actually
takes the variable you put in it you
call the two upper method on it and it
actually does that thing expressions
describe how the lambda does the thing
it describes exactly what that does so
let's break that down a little bit so
again we have two things syntactically
the same which is awesome this is a
property known as Homo iconicity and it
essentially says that the syntax that we
use to not only declare our methods can
be used pretty much almost the exact
same syntax can be used to describe
methods that's a really powerful
characteristic for this language to have
and is one of the most important parts
of when they introduce link and
expressions in general it was one of the
most important things they did because
it makes the development experience
natural if you're using the same syntax
to declare in line functions like this
that you're able to use to describe the
way that inline functions the way they
are in an expression that's a really
powerful concept because it becomes
natural to develop a really powerful
abstraction
okay so let's talk about the different
things that we can do with an expression
we know that an expression describes a
function it describes a function and a
function does something okay
so there's three main uses for them we
can read them we can create them and we
can use them right so we'll start by
talking about what we can do when we
read them
well let's take our two upper front
you're gonna see this guy a lot he's
going to come back because this is a
this is a pretty rote example right
you're going to see him a lot our two
upper friends we have our two upper
friend so this thing can actually be
decomposed right when you've compiled a
method you can't go back and you can get
some information about that in about
that method you can get its number of
arguments it can get its return type and
you can't really do anything else right
but what we can do is break this down
into its component pieces so let's take
art there's two major sides to an
expression right there's the left side
which has the parameter zero to as many
as the CLR will support parameters and
then the right side which is known as
the body of the expression the first
thing we have here on the left side is
we have a property called STR we know
based on the way we declared it
previously it's a string we know that
the parameter is a string so it is a
parameter expression it has two
important properties it has the type of
the parameter expression which is just
string and it also has the name of the
parameter expression which is STR so
when you declare that variable when you
declare that expression inline the name
of that variable would be captured right
there all right very good but then we
have the right side the marks right we
have our body we have the body of the
expression and this is what's called a
method call expression so this isn't
actually a reference to the string dot
to upper method but of course string dot
two up for art upper requires an
instance of something so of course it's
the parameter it's just the parameter
that we passed in okay so that's that's
that's pretty much what an expression is
you're able to look and take this
information at runtime and do you think
with and we'll talk about what some of
those things if I were to replace that
STR on the right side if I call just if
I put it in a if I put Spencer in quotes
and is called to upper this parameter
expression wouldn't be used anymore it
would still be there it could still be
inspected but it wouldn't be using it be
replaced with a constant expression
instead
so not only can we read them more on
that later you can also create them so
we can do this like we've done in line
nothing different and this is really
useful this is really useful because it
allows us to use it with our favorite
libraries like entity framework or Auto
mapper and hibernate whatever your
whatever the things that you use that
use expressions we can use them we can
declare them in life because oftentimes
we know those types ahead of time but
there are plenty of times where there's
a handful of times where it's really
useful to create them at runtime you not
only could declare them inline and you
know all the pipes and all the
information into the body of the
expression ahead of time you can also
create them at runtime so this is what
that looks like this is called the
expression API it's really awesome
the let's pocket let's talk through it
just a little bit with a nice example so
we already know that our function is
compose our expression is composed of
our parameters or arguments and a body
right and that's true for all expression
so a parameter expression is the kind of
frame it is a kind of expression that
represents the parameters into that
lambda right or into that expression and
this is how you declare it right so
there's no new expression you don't know
you know new expression to create a new
expression they use the factory back so
everything is expression dot parameter
or method caller just in this case Paul
so in this case it's just expression dot
parameter and then it creates a new
expression we pass it it's minute
bare-minimum argument is that it needs a
type we need to know the type of that
expression when we're building so we
pass in a type optionally we can also
create provide a meaningful name to that
type in this get into that parameter in
this case my STR you can just send it in
with a name and don't send it in with
the name as the parameters build it
usually pick something like argh zero or
something like that something with less
me
constant expression is another kind of
expression like I described to you
earlier takes a constant it wraps around
a constant something that's either
hard-coded or just read one time a value
that's just stored alongside the
expression so if you do expression dot
constant it takes an object in as its as
its argument and then it just becomes a
constant right you know it's not
anything that's just something that can
be read it's something that can be read
straight from memory it doesn't have to
be inferred
necessary
and then of course we have method call
expression which is very important and
if method call expression represents a
call to a method so what we've done here
is we've taken our expression dot
parameter and this is basically building
our two upper and we'll break through
this a little bit this is building our
to upper thing but the important thing
is this expression call where we give it
something to operate on in this case
it's the parameter and then we give it a
reference to the method using
reflections and there's a couple of
different if you as you explore the
expression API you'll see all the
different ways you can find a find a
method inside of a type but in this case
we just use it just use reflection we
get a call expression call we give it
the instance and then we give it the
method that we want to call okay
let's build our string to upper very
simple we start with expression da
parameters so we've got type of string
and then we want to call it STR because
we're actively building it exactly as we
wanted up here we want to make exactly
that expression
all right then we caught get our
reference to our to upper method because
we know that we call to upper on
something at this point we know we need
to capture we need to need to capture
that we need to use reflection in this
case to just capture it
and then we do our expression calm as we
as I already showed you in the last
slide and then you do this expression
dot lambda so this is the part where you
say you have a body of the expression
you have the parameters let's glue them
together and create our land and that's
what this does
and that's it that's all the lines of
code that we need to write to get this
to upper we get to why that's useful in
just a little bit but it doesn't really
require a lot it doesn't really require
a lot of code it's really natural you
can really reason about so then not only
can you not only can you create them and
read them but you can also use them so
expressions can be compiled right in
memory and then run just like another
method so after you've called expression
dot lambda you've got a reference to a
lambda what's called the lambda
expression and that lambda expression
contains information about it contains
the body in the parameter so once you
call once you get to the point where
expression dot lambda works because if
it doesn't work it'll throw an exception
it'll tell you it's invalid for some
reason you can call dot compile on it
and then you can do dynamic and in this
case dynamic invoke it does not have any
type protections it just takes a
parameter of our art so as long as the
parameter of argument of those that set
of parameters matches the the signature
of the method that you've created with
your expression this will work but it's
not strongly typed you can also use them
like this where you can actually call
expression dot land and give it its type
argument in this case it's func
of string and string and then what you
get back is a once you could do call dot
compile you get a lambda expression of
pipe func of string string and then you
can call compile and then invoke it and
it is actually strongly time so that's
pretty cool
read them use them creative these are
all the different ways that we can do
with expression all right any questions
that's that's yeah that'd be terrible if
this is a real world talk I mean you
came here to see some real world this is
this is about the real world if you came
here to see some action right you didn't
want to just see like how to use the
expression abs let's talk about the real
world we're gonna ease into that by
talking about some of the things that
your favorite library do to use
expressions so we'll just to two simple
example we'll do entity framework and
we'll do auto map because those are two
my favorite
so entity framework it's thing is that
it's translate those link expressions in
deceit right it does a pretty good job
that sometimes a lot of but that is core
thing right if you're talking to sequel
server with I use sequel server with
entity framework it's going to translate
your link expressions it's penetrating
bleeding
so this is a kind of this is a sample of
what you might call to get that secret
right so we've got DB dot products which
is just representing which is a DB if
you might use that to be framework it's
a DD set or just an object that
represents essentially a tape right but
it's a table in memory or it's a
representation of that table so then we
call dot where and then we just want the
products where the name is eggs you just
want egg you just want to see egg and
then we do an order by where we just
order by price in a descending loop so
we want to see the most expensive eggs
books okay pretty normal stuff there's
really nothing special here and this is
roughly what it's going to generate for
you now you've actually seen editing
frameworks queries you know that it
doesn't emit anything that looks
anything like this it looks way weird
right and that's because you know it's
putting it in brackets and it's making
sure that it can run and it's making it
pretty for any different but roughly
this is what comes out of the other end
do you look at this and you say okay
well that's great we have our link
expressions and it translates to sequel
magically we get thing what's the magic
in the middle and it literally just is
matte that's all it is
or at least it can feel that way because
a lot of the times when we how many
people have had an entity framework
entity framework query that they just
hated that they just hated that they
they actually expected the sequel and
they looked at the other end and they
saw or you got a nasty call from a DBA
that's even better
when the DBA yell at you for the queries
that the entity framework corrects it
happens it happened so understanding
what's happening under the hood can
actually kind of help you avoid those
mistakes and one of the important things
that you need to understand is that DV
dot products is an item what's called an
eye query but it's a special type of
ienumerable that can operate on
expressions they're very similar but i
queryable has a ton of power mine let me
show you so this is the type this is the
signature kind of for the most part it's
the signature of dot wave right
you give it a numerable of T and given
an enumerable of T you Paul dot where it
takes in a function that function that
takes in a function that's called a
predicate and the predicate takes in the
object of type T and returns and it
basically says should this object be
returned in this set or not
the queryable so that enumerable is a
static class inside of the link library
variable also a static class but instead
of operating with a function it operates
with an expression so it takes an
expression of func
of T booze and that's really important
because this one can be interpreted by a
library at runtime and that's exactly
what is agreement does it takes this
link query it takes all the stuff that
in behind it and it actually interprets
it at runtime right this isn't compile
this is none of this like the thing that
I one of the things that I struggle with
when I talk about any framework or the
things that junior developers often
struggle struggle with is the concept
that this function is never actually
called in most normal circumstances
right because you're not calling to list
you're not loading them in the memory
first and then operating on them most of
the time most of the time this is
actually just being interpreted at
runtime junior developers have a really
strange time with that I have to go in
and explain like what this is doing
right you have to and I'm sure some of
us have had to do that so expression
visitor is the magic in-between it is
the thing in between it's used to read
and it's used to read expressions and
operate on them and sometimes modify let
me show you so given our sample query
there's sample link query that we have
here this where Clause roughly become
this where clause inside of our link
expression roughly become this see and
that's where the expression visitor
comes in so this expression is known as
a binary expression part the body of
this expression is known it is a as a
binary tree so AB Ryanair expression has
three simple parts it has a left side it
has a right side and has an opera right
so left it is an expression the left
side of that thing is an expression the
right side of that thing also expression
and the thing in the middle called a
node type or whatever you want to call
it is equal or not equal or greater than
or greater than equal to so on and so
forth
expression visitor needs each piece of
these each piece of that expression and
operates on it in a different way
right its goal is to translate in this
case its goal is to translate that link
query to see first thing it does is it
reads the left side it says P name well
I know based on based on the the
expression that I'm able to break down
that this is a property expression dot
name is the property expression it's the
property of the parameter that was
passed in which is the product so knows
it's product dot Nate so it knows that
it's operating on the product iqueryable
or at least that that base thing and
then it looks at that double equals in
the middle and it says oh I know what
that is that's saying it's equal the
binary expression so I know that in
sequel that's actually just an equal
sign right and then of course we've got
your hard-coded eggs which is in quotes
but sequel doesn't do double quotes it
does single quotes so your expression
visitor implementation is actually
taking this and taking it and breaking
it down bit by bit and saying this is
the column name of this from this table
this is the roughly what equals means in
sequel and I say roughly because you
would try to compare equal null inside a
sequel doesn't work and then of course
eggs is not in double quotes and
succinct
but so that's the thing in the middle
that's the magic in the middle now you
could fill an entire day talking about
expression visitor what its power is and
how to do it so we're going to go
through just a couple of quick examples
just to give you a little taste give you
something to kind of chew on a little
bit and it's important to understand
that because this is this is just it
took me a little while to find this
actually took me surprising amount of
time to find this on Stack Overflow it's
an example of a query that was
translated from a linked expression
right this is what it looks like how
many people can read this we can all
read it how many people want to read it
none of us
so that understanding what expression
visitor does under the hood because
c-sharp is not the same as sequel just
not so understanding a little bit just
even a little bit of how it translate
queries can be really powerful and that
also on the enough to fill a day
so expression visitor can use to be used
to read and operate on expressions or
modify them kind of because expressions
that expression API that I showed you
expression dot parameter expression call
all of those things are immutable all
the objects that you get out of that are
mutable which is a good thing but an
expression visitor can be used to modify
that behavior at runtime if you want it
to let me show you this one so this is
an example of an expression and given
this expression visitor what I call dot
visit this is the this is an a method
that you can override does he if you
implement expression visitor it has no
required implementation you can
implement all the things that you just
need to implement in this case I just
want to say if I visit any expression of
anytime I just want to make sure that
anything that I call I want to just type
it in all caps so I have this little
protection here if no type is no
expression type parameter well you can't
call to you up around parameters in this
particular case and then every case so
that doesn't exactly work you have to
just return the base thing but after you
get past that point if your type of your
expression is string because all
expressions have a type associated with
them we're going to call the get method
to get upper method so you can implement
this class to modify your behavior
imagine if you had something where you
said I want to change all the binary
expression you wanted to mess with your
coworker so you wanted to translate all
the binary expressions if there ands
just translate them to ORS and then run
it in production and then look for a job
so you can actually follow along oh no
I've got my little example here let's
walk through this very quickly so we've
got our two upper visitor we're just
instantiating it and we have our
expression up here but we're going to do
is call this to upper visitor dot visit
and convert all it does is take that
expression and just return to the
expression at the same time and then
we're going to console dot write line
Express that compile then call a dynamic
invoke and then the output of that if
you do that is the cheese belongs
percent it's capitalized this part and
it's capitalized this
pretty cool
you can actually look at that this to
upper example is this is a link so go
ahead and click it I'll wait
or you can just check my Twitter
afterwards if this is one of those
things this is using.net fiddle let's
get that out that happy and what that is
if you can go to this to upper visitor
you've got a little bit of code here and
then you can run it and you can see that
I'm not lying to you
it's just basically copied and pasted
from that slide that I showed you the
two upper visitor same stuff here and
then if you zoomed in here it says that
she's belong to Spencer you go and zoom
in on that for maximum like absorption
alright there you go
so that's expression visitor again I
could talk about expression visitors all
day you could do a workshop on it like I
said we're not going to talk about
anymore the important thing to know is
that you have it available it's a tool
insider toolbox
my boss loves to say well let's play
with the Legos that we have this is a
really awesome Lego this is actually
like a box of Lego's inside your Lego
box so at least you know it's there
all right Auto mapper so autumn a purr
has a really simple use case for
expressions and this is some autumn how
many people use automatic alright very
good
so automap is one of my favorite library
seats because it allows you to do some
really cool things it has a lot of
conveniences built in to make our lives
as developers easy so one of its main
use cases is just selecting right
so if given a map between an employee
and an employee model let's say that the
program the property names don't match
up exactly so we could say for the
member the source member the target
member first name we want to get it from
the my first name property on our source
object okay so we're not going to go
through exactly what this is doing the
important thing to do is that the seed
to see into goes into C dot first-name
and the G dot my first name those are
expressions if you look at them the map
from uses expressions they all use
expressions in the hood and this becomes
really powerful when you do something
like project two how many people use
autumn a political check - this is like
ah I like that there's a lot less hands
that time this is Matt let's let me let
me let me show you so consider this
you've got a DBA that already hates you
because you use it a degree so now you
want to say that okay we got this item
detail and let's say it just has like a
hundred and two property than that so it
has an ID primary key a name and then
literally a hundred other property right
and then you have basically a you inside
of a UI that just needs ID and name it
doesn't need any of those other
properties it's just a list of it's just
a list of the products that you want
right so you do something like this how
many people do stuff like this where you
just map it you just call a mapper got
map you just say I just want the item
detail model and you just hand it a set
of data if you've done this before many
many people who use auto map you've done
something like this but here's B the
Dragons because what this is going to do
is in select stock and the reason it's
going to do a select star is it's going
to take DV item details and say um they
want the entire set afterwards I will
evaluate that and then convert it into
item detail model so what you've done is
a select stock right you've selected all
102 problems and your DV a is screaming
at you then knocking down your door
because you're returning way too many
columns or doing these expensive queries
and there's no need to do it
that's where project two comes in
trajectory is one of my favorite parts
of enemy's room or automatic because
what you can do is as long as you have a
map defined you can call that project
two and you can give it just the type of
the item detail model and what and it's
an auto map redundant the foot is it
takes those expressions that I showed
you takes those expressions that I
showed you and then does magic
it just projects it literally projects
that item detail to the item detail
model and it just says oh they just want
the ID and name property and the magic
is so good because it all does this
under the hood and it works with just
about every Auto mapper will do this
with just about every row RM that uses
link it will stay select ID and name
from item details instead of all 102
properties on that op super cool all you
have to do is just instantiate a map so
let's talk about is that we've seen
Italy framework you know the stuff that
magic that happens in between then we
know Auto mapper and all that magic and
we know that we've used libraries like
asp net MVC and razor that have done all
these things so those are great so let's
talk about my real-world experience so a
little bit of background on me usually
people start to talk about but that's
not really that interest so this is
relevant so I'll tell you so I am an I
am a software architect for a start-up
in st. Louis Missouri you look at the
United States it's literally right in
the middle it's pretty boring place to
go you've probably many of you probably
never heard and it felt st. Louis
Missouri and I work for a small start-up
called rim and rivet makes integration
software so they integrate accounting
systems with project management systems
stuff like that
and we had a need as an architect
we had AIIMS are actually a senior
developer for us into the architect role
unbeknownst to me at the time but we
needed to be able to create some kind of
model map because what developers were
doing to transfer the data and this was
this was a system as I inherited you
have and then built on top of that many
of you have right it was basically just
an ETL tool it was a really fancy ETL
tool that did some management of the
foot and essentially when we have
something like a Salesforce customer
QuickBooks customer we want to map those
things together we want to take a
customer from Salesforce and map it to
one in QuickBooks in order to do our
integration magic and then send that
customer all the way up we end up with
models that kind of look like this right
Salesforce customer and it has like
property names that are kind of the same
like create date and open date which
kind of mean the same thing but that's
the meaningful thing that's the
meaningful mapping that we want to
generate and then of course the
Salesforce customer has a customer name
for some reason and then QuickBooks it
doesn't really matter I didn't really
care right I just knew that they were
different and this was this happened all
the time so we would write stored props
or at least my predecessors would write
stored props to move this from one table
into a staging essentially they do an
insert statement on the QuickBooks
customer cuz that's where we wanted to
send the Salesforce person and we'd say
insert the name and the open date select
customer name create date from sales
footprint we do some checking to make
sure that we didn't duplicate date so
this is that we'd write these stored
products now do that for hundreds of
objects and thousands of properties and
don't ever make a mistake because then
you for update okay how many people
writes little procedures of regular for
their job how many people are good at
writing stored procedures I'm putting my
hand down because nobody's good at
writing stories especially stored
procedures with metathesis messy things
like that what we found was that was
that our developer having a really hard
time getting these stored procedures
written in a really consistent good way
so we had something that was just it
didn't scale very well because we'd find
mistakes and we'd often find them when
it was too late when it was downstream
and we've already over wrote some
customers date not good customers do not
like that
so I knew I'd heard about this thing I
had just fresh off another job and I
turned to my boss and I said there's a
way we can do this better since we're
already talking about entities you
already kind of modeled in an entity
framework for both sides we already have
the type information that we need so we
can use I think we could use these
things called expressions now keep in
mind at the time I knew an expression
was I probably came like if I had came
out of this talk I attended this talk I
would have came out with the same
knowledge probably a little more but I
just knew conceptually what they were
and what they could do and I said I
think he can do this better I think we
could create strongly type black
bindings in a way that we could define
two entities together and just make it
generate the secret boy and he said you
have one hour to do a proven concept
okay not to brag but I had something in
40 minutes this was pretty good and he
said man if you worked this if you
worked this well all the time we'd have
everything done like way sooner and I'm
like yeah but then I'd be really tired
and that anyway so essentially what I
built was a way for us to take let's say
we have SF customer to QP customer and
what we'd have is what we would call
them a sequel generator set of stored
procedures we had sequel generators and
what do we do is we give it two types so
we have this is argument this this
examples missing it but we'd have to
type arguments that we say the source
object was Salesforce customer target
object with QuickBooks customer and we
create these really strong binding and
we do stuff like this where we take
source filled customer name is equal to
or we would just say like the desk the
the target field comes from this static
data or this column right it didn't
really matter
so we could say customer name and it
goes to name and then it goes into the
name column inside of the sorry that
comes from the name from the source
object but we want to trim it because a
lot of we work with a lot of legacy
systems and for some reason they love
having leaving leading and trailing
spaces involve working systems that do
this right so we was one of the make
sure that it was true and then we wanted
to create a create we wanted to have a
create date now maybe in the target
system that create date is or that open
date is a required field so we needed to
be able to override it right so we do
create date and if it wasn't there we
just do open date and then we do our
coalesce operator and just safe day time
dot now that'll be close enough we're
developers we're just trying to get it
done we're trying to deliver an
integration product if they hate it down
the road we can always change right so
our task was to write something akin to
an expression VIN there now at the time
I didn't know that expression does it
are existent so I ended up rolling my
own which was kind of which you know you
don't know what you don't know but in
retrospect I feel kind of dumb but I
pretty much reimplemented an expression
visitor and then I needed to be able to
handle any type of expression that we
want to translate now if you do like a
dot starts with a string starts with an
editing framework what's going to do is
translate that into a like state so we
needed to do roughly that same thing we
needed to be able to say okay if we trim
our source data we trim the name from
our source data
then we want to call el trim our trim
inside of secret because all this all
this magic was happening in sequences
right
it was just cooking the sequel for us or
who want to do something like this we
what that's that's obviously it is null
right that's it roughly that's pretty
much the same thing inside a sequel so
we take that that that expression right
there that coalesce operator expression
and we would call is null instead and
we'd say create date and then we'd even
go so far as to be able to say date time
now is actually get date inside a sequel
server but generally you should have
your targets cysts that your your
running system tell the sequel server
the date not the other way around
that's another sort you get the idea
right date time dot now gets interpreted
and we can translate that if we wanted
to insight into get date so what it did
what we ended up with is what we ended
we ended up with something that could
emit nice-looking secret it didn't admit
like too crazy a sequel and it did and
it's supported a lot a large range of
operations support of joins and we could
just support we could basically just
join kind of like we do it in entity
framework but we could do it actually we
made it even more convenient for
developers we could do joins with when
we need a data from other entities right
then we can send that it admitted
nice-looking secret it was predictable
because we had a set of tests fine we
wrote at all we wrote a bunch of tests
to cover it and it saved developers
thousands of hours over a two or three
year period now that is that is money in
the bank that is not only money in the
bank that's delivery that is being able
to like when Sony would say oh we need
to make we need a sequel generator and
we'd say oh that's that's no problem
well we can crank those out pretty
quickly right then we don't have to
worry about stored procedures and the
best thing was is that we could attach
all this sorts of logic under the hood
to say like well we actually need to do
these other transformations right we
need to make the platform aware of those
relationships and we could do that
because we would just run a bunch of
extra sequel under the hood as part of
this thing it will all be wrapped in a
transaction now down the road we found
problems with this we've actually moved
on from this but at the time it was
super powerful and it's saved a lake
that allowed us to deliver software
really quickly and it saved us a lot and
it saved
we're at best part developers didn't
hate there
they weren't writing school
so that's my real-world example let's
talk about some let's talk some maybe
some closer one maybe if you're an asp
net api provider or something like
you're an api provider writing an asp
net so let's say we want to order by
string not not a string property but
literally give it a property name as a
string as opposed to giving it like an
expression right at runtime so we maybe
want to do something like this we recall
a pro wreath provide an endpoint where
we want to say oh you want to order by
the data that you want to get back maybe
you can just provide this parameter
order by equals name now if you like o
data you could always install o data and
you kind of get this for free but if you
don't want to do that or you wanted
something more custom you could do
something like this right if this is the
goal this is the goal but it's not like
you're gonna have a case statement where
you say oh if it's name then order by CC
into name right I mean you might if you
didn't know what you had expressions you
might actually do that I've done stuff
like that and it works but you could
save yourself keystrokes let me show you
we can do something like this we could
roll our own this thing right and it
could be really useful so our solution
is to cook an expression so our goal is
to get to this this link right let me
say order by and we want to go see dot
name we want to don't want to do that
case statement cuz maybe there's a
thousand property you don't want to
write a case a switch statement with a
thousand things so this is roughly what
it might look like but we've got our it
takes our iqueryable so we're it takes
our queryable expression and then it
takes the property name or field name if
you use field and then you can give it a
rule to say if you want it to be
ascending or descending right you could
also do it where you have order by
property or field descending right you
can have that implementation we'll stick
with this one print for our goal is to
cook our expression and then apply it to
our iqueryable chain
but we're going to take our c2c that
night we're gonna we're gonna this is
that this is the goal this is what we
need to bring out of this so when our
method we need to capture the type of
team all right we don't know what type T
is we just want to know that we want to
order by something on type e so we
capture that element and then we say
expression dot parameter when we capture
that type that represents the parameter
to the expression that we're cooking
right that it represents with soul
parameter to the order bite to the order
by clause and then we can do this
expression dot property or field there's
also expression dot property proper to
your field is pretty useful though where
you give it a thing an expression to say
this is the instance we wanting to find
the property for and here's the name of
that property now the cool thing here is
if that's if that line doesn't find a
property with that name it throws an
exception so you can always handle that
and say like invalid order by or just
ignore the exception and let the query
go through right you have that choice
and then you cook up expression dot
lambda you give it your property that's
the thing that's the body of the
expression and then you give it your
type of T or the parameter that you've
wrapped in your type of T that's the
parameter and then you've created C goes
into C dot name the same thing up there
pretty awesome
so remember this is our goal so we need
to do just a few more things because our
goal is to call this method we need to
call the order by method on the
queryable static class so in order to do
that you use a little reflections where
it gets a tiny bit hairy so this is what
it looks like so we need a method name
so we have order by order by descending
since we just said in art we just have a
parameter inside of that thing bool is
sending you see if it's sending is true
then just do order otherwise you order
by descent and then this is the
expression call this is where the part
where I tell you that this is like you
need to kind of look at the expression
API we've never used it before and
experiment with it because this is kind
of nasty to look at right
like this is I could describe to you in
great detail what this is it's just a
type signature or a multitude of methods
that are available to represent your
expression but going through it quickly
you need to capture the order by or
order by descending method on our
queryable object so we say here's the
type since it's a static class we need
to give it we need to get the type of it
so we can just look for that method we
need to method name
we need the type signature of that
method cooking it's custom we need the
expression that we're querying for and
then we need our selector that selector
being the method that we cook up right
here
all right
so not gonna go through that because
what I'm gonna do instead is show you in
dotnet I'm not gonna show you but I want
to show you that it exists so order
probably property example I have a
dotnet fiddle that does exactly that
let's quit er Oh order by with that and
I - and if you look at that on yeah here
is it just a dotnet fiddle in a little
bit and what I have here is just giving
it order by property or field name and
what it'll do is write this set of
employees in order you can see we have
Gary Spencer Michael and Amy so when we
run this since we called order by
property field name we get a or me Gary
Michael Spencer in in order so that's
pretty cool and this is attached there's
a link to this that attached to a paging
example I did in ASP debts and you can
actually see it and to end you can
actually download look at this example
and see the whole thing it's a few years
old so it will probably compile but
you'll get the idea right because you'll
see you'll see the whole thing you'll
see it from asp net all the way down to
when you cook the expression so pretty
handy alright more real-world stuff how
about your own rules engine or search
filter system or whatever right you
could easily you can see how easily it
would be able to take that thing that I
just showed you and just copy paste it
into aware right and create some kind of
rules engine so let's do that let's do
that right here so let's define
something called a rule and this example
is a little bit wrote so what we
basically want to do is represent a
binary expression but we want to
represent this in a data structure of
sometimes we want to store this or we
want to be able to take from some JSON
and just did deserialize it into
something that's meaningful to c-sharp
and then cook an expression with it well
you can do that very easily with
expression do we have our rule it says
given this name of this property and
this operation or operator and this
value we want to say Oh name is equal to
Gary or higher date is greater than 1 1
2016 stuff like that
so we do that we define our data either
you serialize it from Jason Orient is
hard-coded for this example we have our
name operation dot equal name equal
declare gary hire date equal the day
time right so then what we can do is
cook what we could cook a binary
expression and just to break this down
very quickly what we need to do is take
these rules essentially and translate
them into an expression for each of
these things so we say we're going to
capture the property of that parameter
we know the parameter coming in is going
to be in a type employee we're going to
capture that praten a that property
we're gonna grab the property name we're
going to take the constant value the
right side of our binary expression and
our left which is our property we have
our right which is our constant and then
we know that our rule our operation rule
it's either equal or greater to greater
or greater than or equal to or greater
than we capture that and we call this
called make binary and what it'll do it
will make that binary expression for you
and then we just set it to the binary
expression that we declared up here we
just set it to null and we if it's set
to null we just set it to that or we
create a new binary expression where we
essentially pass in and also so we
create a chain of binary expressions
depending on on the rules if you look at
the code of under the hood if you look
at this expression under the hood if you
declared it like this you would see that
this is just a series of binary
expressions that are all operating on
each other and so this is what this
becomes you got your e you've translated
your rule up here you've got name equal
to Garry and hire date equal or greater
than to any city 1 1 2016 pretty cool I
have an example here to will tweet that
out click
we'll send an example keep that out
pretty sweet awesome and then if I I
will show you real quick if I run it
here but we've got our same set of
employees and we have our rules right
here so we're looking for named Gary
hire date
1 1 2016 we've taken these rules that
we've declared as as code as day or
sorry as data and then created an
expression down here to actually cook
that up and then use it and we have Gary
1 1 2017 if you change that to Amy and
reran it I don't remember what hire date
was hired and is not bad apparently we
run that and hope we have an Amy record
oh we don't have
there we go now when we run it now we
get a me so what you've done is you've
just declared some kind of way to
represent an expression inside of data
and then you knew how to use expressions
because you went to this awesome talk
and you were able to translate that and
make your own movement now there's a
bunch of rules engine implementations
out there right so that's nothing new
but now you can kind of understand under
the hood what's happening and you can
tweak it if you want we actually use
four years ago we had a rules int and I
said this is not sufficient so we're
going to make it we're going to make
some changes to it make it better
because I knew at that point enough and
to know how to be make it better do I
new expressions or in practice with them
long enough no
there's like a multitude of things that
you can do so let's talk a little bit
about expressions versus reflection how
many people are moderate to heavy users
of reflection okay me too
I love reflection it is one of the
greatest parts of the length and parts
of the CLR
I love reflection so it's reflection
expressions are you can think of them as
a nice abstraction over reflection but
reflection is theory in theory it's more
powerful right you can use it you can
actually emit the il to actually like
run and create these massive expressions
make it really convenient to do that so
you don't have to do that reflection is
also can be considered if you're just
reflecting on you know get that if
you're calling get value on some object
and passing a property name to get the
value that's really slow or at least
that's what developers say expressions
can kind of speed that up because what
you can do is you can take that
reflection cache a delegate that right
from using expressions you can cache a
delegate you can compile one in memory
and then reuse it and expressions once
they're compiled they are just as fast
as they're practically they're virtually
as fast as a method that you would
declare in line so expressions can be
really fast reflection used to solve
very similar problems can solve them a
little slower but I use them in tandem
right I use expressions mainly to create
library for developers to use that are
really convenient and then reflection
under the hood to do all the really
magic step right so really just depends
on your use case one when you would use
one or both right or neither than that
in that case
there are some dragons here be the
dragons right so expressions are not
perfect they are not a perfect
abstraction and one thing about
extractions they're great but they leave
if strategy expressions are not perfect
for example how many people love the
question mark dot operator that was
introduced you know the last seashell
version take is awesome right
that thing is great you can't use it an
expression because expressions came
before that feature was available so if
you actually tried to declare an
expression with the question mark it
says you can't do it and will compile
the reason you can't do it I mean it's a
good thing imagine if entity framework
six had to go back and refactor all
their code just to be able to use that
question it sucks a little bit but it's
actually a good thing in the doesn't
support but it also you got to
understand that the c-sharp compiler
does magic it does a lot of magic for so
let's take these expressions finally
something a little different than the
two upper again so we've got combined
strings it's just a reimplementation of
string dot can cat right before we date
where we give it a function where we
have two strings and then we return on
the other end those strings concatenate
right so if we do the top one or the
bottom one doesn't matter they don't
exactly look like this when you look at
them as an expression let me show you if
you tried to do this expression
parameter string one string two and then
you did this make binary and you said
well that's an additive expression right
expression dot add string one parameter
this will throw and it will say the
binary operator add is not defined for
the type system string assistant rig
you're like well what I just did that
what is what's this
what visit I just did and literally just
use it because under the hood C sharp is
doing magic for you compilers doing
magic for this uses string dot can be
had you inspected this into expression
under the hood it's not a binary
expression this is all to spring back in
cat
right ah so it's not always the case
where you can take and this is just a
very narrow set but you have to be aware
of it it's not always the thing where
you can just take this look at it and
say that's a binary expression doesn't
always work like that for the most part
it does but c-sharp does magic for
conversions have to be handled
explicitly this is a this is kind of
annoying really but like if you if you
have an expression that takes a function
that has a parameter that takes a
parameter of a specific type let's say
actually if it just takes object and you
try to pass in an employee object
expression into that it will throw an
error you actually have to convert it to
object because when you when you do that
what is happening is under the hood
c-sharp is actually like casting it's
doing a cast cast it's an object right
yours it's not aware of that because you
don't have to but casting a conversion
for the most part have to be handled
explicitly when you're cooking custom
expressions so you will find oh you'll
find that out as you're messing with
expression you will find out the
limitations pretty quickly pretty fun so
how to start what do you do I'd start by
experimenting and my favorite tool to
experiment or link pad or Google I've
used Google to look up expression stuff
to this date when I need to
don't ever memorize or dine sign said
don't ever like memorize anything you
can just look up right I do not have
every expression dot like tight
signature for all those methods I did
not have them all memorized that just
would not be practical so I usually
experiment I will use link pad or I'll
even use that dot that fiddle which is a
good tool for things like this that make
it really easy for you all to run it and
for experimenting with the expression ap
I'd use link pattern even Visual Studio
code something like that
and just do it we do best using
telescopes right no shame in my game
I'll tell you I use intelligence
intelligence to discover stuff about
expressions when I use them every time I
you write use your tooling boolean's
there to help and most importantly did I
mention experiment you should experience
great that's just the bottom line
they take those examples that I've had
my previous time I gave this talk I
didn't have those examples and I was
like that would be super helpful that's
super cool now you can click and you
know run expressions all day really
awesome it's my opinion
so that's the end of my talk if you have
any questions please
afterwards and this is not the end of
our conversation if I I'm gonna fly home
to tomorrow actually and if you have a
question just reach out to me at
Schneider Mach is the best way to reach
out to me so it is a pleasure it has
been a pleasure to be at NBC for tow I
have had so much fun and involved in
very gracious so thank you very much
have a great rest of the conference
[Applause]